so I need to present you and work with
them wrong and twisting good being
suggest since this is a workshop I
thought I'll present some more advance
on going quite now so this is working
progress so just a warning before I
start so what my generalization Theory
offer deep learning one thing we hope it
might offer its explanation explanation
of empirical journals Asian performance
we might expect it might offer ability
to predict the results of interventions
on the learned algorithm you know the
theory sorry precise it might even offer
prescription decision for how to improve
generalization designing algorithms with
them to improve generalization
guarantees or even do model selection
I'd like to argue that what a lot of
different Theory actually offers is
merely suggestion so it lacks
explanation the bonds that we have are
empirically numerically bankers and
cannot explain generalization on their
own as bounce at least so what people
usually do is those hoc empirical
correlation studies that provide some
sort of evidence that the quantities in
the bandar are relevant it also relaxed
prescriptions model selection using
these banks usually leads to severe
under fitting and this is because the
bouncer lewis you're usually over
regularizing of course people have turn
quantities they find in the bounce into
algorithms but then post hoc empirical
work is needed to actually tune
complexity hyper parameters again not
over regular eyes so community has
highly focused on asymptotics of non
asymptotic bands and of course this work
is essential and foundational but more
attention needs to be paid to have a
leading theory in berkeley and seeking
complete understanding so what could be
a goal for for statistical dank theory
that could push things forward so one
ambitious goal of course is finding
Kanaan backers vice-versa casts a
gradient descent let us be the training
sample and use some random source let
each I'll be the classifier produced by
tsukasa gradient descent or some hyper
parameters theta that achieves 1%
Rainier now the challenge is to identify
function sign and food that verb high
probability the risk for the classifier
returned by stochastic
send this upper bonnet in terms of this
function sign so it's like in depends on
the hyper parameters on the training set
on the random source and Sal's about
statistical bound and a requirement is
for site to be better than a guessing
grade or a deal even tied close to the
tests error on standard the benchmarks
we don't have anyone back whose band's
first I guess we didn't sent but we do
have bounds for stochastic neural
networks or for a compressed neural
network so this is recent work by show
at all presented at I clear this year we
also have bands for differentially
privates the category innocence to be
served
stochastic variants like noise severe
insufficient team in all these cases
tighter bands come at a cost of under
settings so there seems to be a
trade-off between how tired of the
guarantee can get and how good you are
classifier that you obtain us so what
are the barriers to explaining
generalization one barrier one type of
barrier statistical so our bought my
depend on quantities that we don't know
for example on the unknown data
distribution and we only have access to
the data distribution wire samples now
best bands are four undertrained noise
network so is it even possible to have
tie bands for high performance networks
I never tried another a number type of
various computational so again our bonds
might depend on quantities that are
intractable and yet their number types
analytical and perhaps right bands you
know they may not even have been
invented yet
we made our the talk I'll revisit the
back based framework for generalization
balance I'll discuss free principles for
obtaining tighter generalization
guarantees and I will apply that for the
moment network setting so just reminder
the last part of the talk would really
focus on the ongoing problems
like this bounce yelled risk for gifts
classifies which I will define in a
minute let me define introduce some
notation first so let H be the
hypothesis class let L be the last
function that map's hypothesis and
training data to a bandit interval 0 1
risk as usual will be defined as the
expected loss and empirical risk as the
average loss or trained ear it gives
master fire it's a probability
distribution over your hypothesis class
so we can interpret this as a randomized
classifier by looking at the definition
off of its risk so the risk of the Gibbs
classifier Q is the expectation over the
draws from Q of the loss so we can
rewrite this expectation as a double
expectation when we first draw a sample
from the training data from the data
distribution and then we draw a
classifier and we evaluate the loss on
this random draw let me now say the bank
based organization guarantee for Gibbs
classifiers so for the remainder of the
clock will be we'll be dealing with by
no cost functions nature chooses the
other disability we choose a prior
distribution P on the weights so in this
case it's a Gaussian the nature gives us
the training data set s now we know the
empirical risk surface then with high
probability for all posterior
classifiers Q the risk or the or the
class of our queue is upper bounded in
terms of its empirical risk plus the
scale divergence term between Q poster
and P prime classifier so looking at
this example on the right we could place
let's say a Gaussian posterior
distribution Q in this minimum region we
are allowed to have quite a bit of
variance the vaad incurring too much
training care and the kill divergence
term between Q and P is probably
relatively small so we get a quite a
tight guarantee we could also place a
different class for Q prime in this very
kind of narrow minimum region Q has to
be Q prime has to be really concentrated
not to incur a lot of training error so
don't want our training error to remain
small so it has to be real concentrated
and of course now the kill divergence
between Q and P is way larger so that
this gives a much weaker guarantee for
this class for Q prime compared to Q
because rewrite this type baseband as a
ban on the square generalization here so
we just you know rearrange some terms
and in fact that this bouncer can be put
on for any convex function on the loss
on the risk and empirical risk and then
on the right hand side we get a kill
divergence between Q and P and this log
term that depends on the convex function
you chose so thank yous banks are for
randomized Skip's classifiers can I just
ask so it's part of the point that you
don't know a priori how to choose Q in a
principled way as you're gonna produce
to proving something there's something
that holds for all Q
it seems very strong to have a statement
that holds for every cube well this
gives the extra flexibility so in fact
I'll be talking later that there aren't
optimal Q's but it really depends what
algorithm you wanna you want to get
going to use for so Q like the most
important thing here is that Q is data
dependent so it can be chosen in any way
using the training data and P has to be
chosen before you get the training data
that's kind of the only
see I think this Lancer for Gibbs
classifiers randomized classifiers and
ideally want to get again T at the end
for the term is a classifier that we get
from a CD and there is a growing
literature on techniques to construct
the base bounce on deterministic
classifiers so one old idea is exploit
margin to do randomized these randomized
ISO fires so this particular picture is
for SVM's
from some ultra older work and more
recently people have kind of used these
same ideas for in the neural net setting
so for example this result by nation
burg at all so in in this particular
case we first fix a margin gamma then
for our deterministic classifier H we
construct a randomized class for Q that
satisfies this margin condition so
basically what we wanted to be sample
and classifier from Q we want the output
of the function not to change too much
so be kind of the perturbation has to
keep you within the margin then the high
probability you get banned on the
deterministic class of our H so the risk
of determines classifier H is now upper
bandit in terms of its empirical margin
loss plus the KO term so there are other
ways to construct kind of do randomized
package bounce one of them is
disintegrating disintegrated versions of
time base this is work due to Kotani one
of our more recent approaches approaches
is combining pack base with generic
chaining now just to recap we want
bounce for scatter grading descent so
for something deterministic for
determinist class where i beget out at
the end so it's wrapping B's plus margin
approach to Bionic HD risk in order to
deer randomize we need posterior queue
that is tightly concentrated around the
weights obtained by stochastic gradient
descent now in order to control the
cable complexity term we need the prior
beat to have sufficient mass near the
stochastic gradient solution and
actually these two things are really in
tension right so there is like a
trade-off kind of you know when for
queue to be tight you want the prior to
be kind of might and they were around
here now this needs to be
vulva volatility no the data
distribution or using some other
training data how would we know where to
Center our prior P so it seems to be
hard so people have attempted to just
generally tighten thank these balance
let me mention a few approaches so one
of them is optimize the posterior view
so it's quite well known that for a
fixed prior distribution P there is an
optimal posterior distribution Q and it
takes the following form so its density
is proportional to exponentiate at
empirical risk now we will not be taking
advantage fully of this or this
flexibility because we're interested in
getting guarantees for a specific
algorithm and changing changing here
would be like changing your algorithm
and our approach towards tighten bank
based pontus optimizing the prior so for
a fixed learning algorithm q so now the
Q's fixed there exists an optimal prior
so again this is older work so the
optimal prior is just the expected
posterior distribution now to get this
we need to know the data distribution
and our most recent work we actually
showed that you can optimize over the
subsets of the training data that you
use to estimate the mountain so I'll
talk about this in a bit so let me just
tell you a little more about this
approach for getting these optimal prior
distributions ultimate priority is
expected expectation of U so thank this
prior can't depend on data distribution
deal but it cannot depend on the
training data s but our only handle on
the data distribution aspire the samples
we get so how does it seem impossible it
seems you know really hard right
so people have tried so there are a
couple of different approaches that
people have tried one of them is
distribution dependent priors so you
constraint this some form of
distribution dependent prior which is
spherical priority don't really have
accessed it but then you upper bound the
keo divergence for this particular prior
the different approach is using data to
concern the prior so again and in 2007
2012
there there's quite a quite a bit of
work on constructing the abatement and
priors really to get towards this data
distribution dependent prior we also
have worked from last year we use we use
all the training data to learn the prior
but in some safe way so in particular we
use differential privacy to to formalize
this so we were tall in 2010 we study
priors and post earring so the following
form the prior posterior are the
densities are proportional to
exponential at true risk and empirical
risk respectively
so this prior is really accurate ago
prior right we don't really have direct
access tit and both of these depend on
this parameter gamma that will call
inverse temperature so the the higher
the inverse temperature parameter so the
lower the temperature the more
concentrated posterior distribution will
be around it's risk minimizer we'll be
showing this work that then the cam
divergence for between Q and P so for
this particular choices can be upper
bondage of high probability in terms of
the inverse temperature parameter gamma
now of course once we have bound the
kill divergence we can plug it back into
any fact this bunch really and get a
bound on the on the the difference
between risk and empirical risk in terms
of this parameter gamma this kind of
data data distribution dependence comes
for this parameter inverse temperature
parameter and you know if we if we need
only small gamma to actually get pretty
good empirical error for Q then we'll
get capital guarantee we validate these
bands and fear clear so I think this
particular part is for M is data set
so these two overlapping client lines
are training testers so that the a
little higher one is the test here the
bottom one is the trainer the green line
on the bottom is the generalization
you're so just the gap between the two
so it's zero for a small values of gamma
and it's kind of still very small for
larger values of gamma one thing I would
like to draw your attention to is that
it's an increase like parameter gamma
our generalization here doesn't really
increase in fact it even looks like a
little smaller smaller here them for
example here now this dominant line is
liebherr liebherr bound on the
generalization error so initially it's
quite tight but as we increase the
parameter gamma it starts really
exploding can becomes vacuous pretty
much at the point where they're starting
to learn well not really I guess we're
learning here but you know it's kind of
around here what you care about is it's
bankers and maybe here you can kind of
get a guarantee so it seems like this
parameter gamma is really for kind of
some kind of kind of worst-case scenario
and it comes from really upper binding
to kill divergence so on the right hand
side is a simple ad for amnesty on
demise labels so there is no signal on
that data anymore
so the tester is always around the
guessing great the training gear
decreases so we need a higher gamma for
the training carrier to be really small
in this case the generalization here is
this Green Line so initially it's zero
once we start learning it jumps to
pretty much maximum and the lever bound
is vislaud of line again here so again
initially it's small and as we increase
gamma it starts it starts increasing and
you can see that actually pretty well
captures the true channelization error
gap which is the Green Line so it does
seem like this bond cannot really
capture data dependence too well
so in summary Lieber at all bound
smackers once gamle is large enough to
fit on a label data sets now recall that
Bank B's priority can depend on the data
distribution but not the data itself but
the data is our only handle on the dream
training this data distribution so the
idea is to use some of the training data
or sorry to use all the training data
choose the priority but in a way that is
stable to changes in the training data
so that the prior would be almost
independent of the training data so this
is how our work from from our last
year's paper
New York's where we show that if the
priority is learned in an absolute
differentially private way then with
high probability we get exactly the same
plank base about as before but now with
this additional error term that depends
on the privacy level so if prior if
priority is learned with an algorithm
that has a lot of differential privacy
so epsilon is really small we'll have
very small risk small error small
additional penalty if we have not too
much differential privacy epsilon is
large we'll current incur a lot of
additional error
we're using our training data this sum
is - correctly this bounded lever right
I pronounce because Servite maybe I
didn't understand a slide but it was
this Gibbs measure on the risk gamma at
times the risk and so that thing is
sensitive to labels so I'm not
understanding where this argument it is
well the upper bond and the kill
divergence right so they don't you don't
have access to the true data
distribution it's not that you can
actually write down this prior I thought
you were cheating no no so in this case
like the bt the pram poster of this form
but then because they cannot access this
prior in anyway the upper bond to kill
divergence I mean really the looseness I
think comes in this upper bound what if
we we made a cheating bounder instead
using the the Cal the business we Monte
Carlo or whatever and we actually
evaluate this thing and then then it
seems like it could be pretty good I'm
not sure how mentor Carla would help you
cheat you would still need so maybe you
could use on top some differential
privacy or something right to be able to
or maybe a held out training set to
estimate for the virus maybe that's what
you're talking about looks like it can't
tell apart angry so one thing we could
do I guess we could take like a totally
fresh data set from the scene theater
distribution evaluate try to approximate
this distribution dependent prior and
try to see what the bond would look like
then for these particular choices so
this is not the optimal prior really
right but it's still distribution
dependent so it's maybe it's close but
of course once you upper bound it as he
did then you get this kind of worst case
not real worst case may be but you know
first case
video that's one approach you could see
if that would really test how optimum
this briar is in general how close does
it talk to me my question I was trying
to get where the boys casing over labels
in it and it's created two lines
so the challenge from using this
differentially privatbank basement is
that differential privacy is hard to
achieve so one solution we propose is by
showing that just merely being closed in
Washington distance to private mechanism
suffice is to yelled a valid
generalization banned so you don't
actually need to sample from a
differential private algorithm but it's
enough to be close now there is some new
other stability related approaches by
River splats at all from last year
see numerous approaches exist trying to
approximate this optimal prior so either
analytically using data or using privacy
but it's approximating P star actually
optimal so this is that the usual bank
based bounds on the top on the left hand
side we evaluate the empirical risk term
of Q when our all of our training data
and on the right hand side we divide by
all of you know the number of samples we
have in the training data M so this is
just the size of your training set of
course you could reserve some data as
prime and only evaluate the risk term R
on s naught s prime then you're
effectively divided by smaller number in
this right hand side and I are allowed
to use this reserved data to learn the
prior so if we only use as not as prime
to estimate transition error then the
optimal prior takes the following form
so it's a conditional expectation of Q
would we ever want to do this so the
answer is yes and that's what we shown
our most recent work so even if you have
access to the true data distribution
it's still optimal to use some of the
data so informally there is a
distribution loss and learning
algorithms and pretty clearly she did
our example that you constraint such as
a back dismount of Oracle prior his back
is but symbol and a subset as not as
prime before occur prior which is now
this conditional prior conditional
expectation is non bankers so it's
actually optimal to use some data even
if you have access to the data
distribution
just recap in order to relate q2 to kind
of our original goal so in order to
relate Q to stochastic gradient descent
weights W star
we need posterior that's tightly tightly
concentrated around the weights learned
by stochastic gradient ascent and in
order to control the kill complexity
term we want to use now some data to
crops approximate data dependent Oracle
prior which is the conditional
expectation of Q given our reserved data
then the empirical risk term in the
bound is computed on as and not just
prime where m was used to learn the data
so how might we approximate this new
data an Oracle dependent prior should I
think of this as being like I get to
choose s fun like at random
it doesn't matter we're gonna have to
very carefully curate which s prime
yeah so I you could choose it at random
if you carefully curate you would need
to add a penalty if maybe like right you
know bother is something like that yeah
carefully choose exactly so but somehow
your theorem is okay I just choose it
you know to be like half of the day that
random or something yeah so it's so it's
it's totally like it's kind of obvious
why you can move some of the data but
what's less obvious is that up till now
people only it took those like you know
the optimal prior is far to be this only
distribution dependent prior right so
the optimal POS expectation of Q which
really the theorem is about that not
only you can move the training data and
use some of the Nvidia to just made the
prior but actually saw two more in some
cases
so that's really kind of the novelty
so consider a Gaussian prior fee and
posterior Q so Q digs a following forms
a Gaussian centered at the output of
stochastic gradient descent with some
diagonal covariance matrix the prior is
also a Gaussian centered at some weights
W bar better learn from a subset of the
data s prime and has isotropic coherence
so it's just lambda times identity now
they came a divergence between these two
gaussians as to the following form and
this part really depends on the on the
weights and the prior versions and this
is just depending on the variances of
Brian posterior
so once the prior means W bar is fixed
we are free to optimize the diagonal
covariance matrix of our posterior now
we must choose the prior mean W bar
before we see the full training data s
so ideally we want W bar that minimizes
this this term that depends on time will
you bar so we end up with the following
animation problem now we cannot really
solve this exactly but ideally we could
just you know this this really relates
the kind of Wasserstein
distance ideas and coupling but I'll not
go into the details that I were really
just approximated to using stochastic
gradient descent
so first the Casa green the scent I
forgot to add so of course we also have
some other random nice EU so for example
what mini-batch should we choose
so we want to use the cash agreed and
sent really to predict the castrating
sent so W star should be equivalent to
HDD on the full data set and since s
prime is a subset it's a random subset
of all the data we're free to choose as
prime to be first data process by
stochastic gradient sense so we want as
prime to choose B chooses prime in a way
that it's the same data that sarcastic
gradient and descent access accesses for
the first few iterations of training
so the approximate W bar by running
stochastic gradient descent on this
subset of prime to convergence and by
design stochastic gradient descent on
aspire will match the initial behavior
of stochastic gradient descent on us we
can just totally match it because we
have access to the same data so here is
a toy example these blue lines are just
empirical risk surface we run stochastic
we initialize the Cask reading this in
here we run out we end up at the minimum
because it's a convex problem now we
could place the but knowing clearly that
it's a the data distribution or having
access the data one thing that we could
do for you know as a default is a
baseline we could Center the prior
distribution here so here we Center a
Gaussian at random initialization could
also like I talked about in the previous
lines you could use some of the training
data so a small fraction on the training
data to train the prior using stochastic
gradient descent so initially it boasts
the category in descent which is on full
data which is a blue line and the Christ
green innocent on this subset of the
data they run together and eventually
the the green line jacilla sterzick has
agreed in descent
running on the small subset of the dear
that the prior has access to now we can
place a garrison here instant
yeah
okay so we could place a Gaussian for
the prior here which is already a bit
closer to the final final weights
achieved by stochastic readings and all
of the data you could of course use even
more of the data or even more of the
data now would be a really close but of
course the the more the data we use the
lower the number so I don't have the
fact-based bound here but well the lower
the lower the number is that we divide
the KL divergence mine so there is a
trade off
yeah sorry so so now we have we serve
with the bound where and we compute
everything out Gloria now we have a
bound will be split the data into two
pieces we use the first part as to make
some parts the bound and then we use the
second part for some other parts of them
so if I'm in this regime that where I'm
splitting data and using two halves for
different parts of the bound for me the
natural baseline is just a validation so
I just take the other part of data and
compute yeah so one thing is we we don't
take any data out of the the original
HDD run so HD is like that the W star
wins so it should deal on the full data
it's it's a lot of taxes all of the data
so we don't really split the data and
give half of the data to the training
algorithm that we care about in the ever
had just for a validation I should be
still learning on all of the data but
now we just used half of the data tool
in the prior and we're dividing by
smaller numbers and involving them break
or risk number one okay my question is
still valid directly let's do this then
so we do your thing we get some bound
and the other thing we can do is we
train on half the first half the data
can I just use the other half to create
a validation error so do you know how
these do you yeah so you'll be learning
one half of the data first of all right
so you'll get potentially a worst
classifier second using this for
addition it doesn't give you any insight
really why the algorithm works or
doesn't work so the kind of words we're
aiming towards is perhaps by doing this
we'll get to some structure that will
then tell us why is the cassock reading
The Sentinel Isis or doesn't or maybe
you know some structure of interest so
that you could you then use to get
differentiation bounds so just using
held-out data doesn't really tell us
much
it might give a tighter guarantee at the
end probably would but it isn't give us
any inside
this is a toy example we apply it on
neural networks - so this particular
plot is for fashion em nests on em like
- hidden lire no Network but they got
the same results for MSC for ten on comm
nets and so on the x axis we plot alpha
this which is a fraction of the data
accessed by the prior and on the y axis
we plot the squared the L square little
- norm between the weights learned by
stochastic readings and all the data
versus weights learnt by this fraction
of the data as expected this distance is
decreasing the higher the alpha but of
course which we really care about us
when this distance is normalized by the
number of training data that we have
left or that the prior hasn't seen so
even when we normalize we see that
actually it is better to use some of the
training data to learn the prior
distribution
now here we also optimize the back days
bouncing the previous plot I was just
showing you the means how the means get
closer now here we are we also allowed
ourselves to optimize the posterior
variance so how tightly were
concentrated around this hid solution
and we evaluated thank these bound so
again on the x axis you see alpha so on
the left hand side is just a fully
connected network on the right hand side
and convolutional network on the x axis
you see alpha on the y axis the the loss
the the line with the circles is the
test ear or the randomized classifier
and this is the generalization band that
we get so in both cases we see that
actually it is better in America later
to use some of the training data to
learn the prior how well are we actually
predicting the way it's learned by
stochastic gradient descent so you're on
the x-axis are the weights learnt from
the this prefix data store from this
fraction of the data that the prior can
access and on the x-axis it's the
weights learn by stochastic gradient
running on all the data so this is that
initialization comparing the weights at
initialization versus the the weights at
the end of training and higher the value
K beam we see that we can actually even
for K equals 0.1 we can predict the
weights pretty well so somewhat
surprising how well the weights are
predicted but it's still not good enough
when there are millions of parameters so
the kill term is actually still large so
how do we make progress you could
perhaps make better predictions on the
mean so we could you know maybe
decreases this trade or to Murom but
it's not clear this is possible how much
could a better prior covariance help
because one thing we didn't really do is
we didn't do anything clever the prior
covariance so forget Gaussian prior P
with diagonal covariance matrix the KO
trim takes the following form so how
much could an Oracle estimate of this
lambda help optimizing the kale bond in
terms of lambda we obtain that the kale
equals to this to this expressions of
course we cannot do this to get a valid
bound but we just want to really test
the limits if some Oracle came and and
told us what the optimal
Baron says diagonal how better could our
Bambi so this band represent the best
who could hope to achieve and allows us
to test limits our proposed me a
prediction w bar so this is the same
plot as before now note actually within
these plots we learned only on half of
Emma's data set for reasons that I might
tell you about so the left-hand sides
again the fully connected Network on the
right it's Lin at five now this is a
band as before where there where the
prior variance is not really learned now
if we set the primaries to this Oracle
variance we see improvement and there's
quite a bit of improvement actually and
the band does seem to be quite tight
around here
in this case we also tried to push this
idea even a little more more to the
extreme so we used something that we
call the ghost sample so as I mentioned
earlier this is only trained on half of
them you see that says so we used the
other half to train the prior like quit
training the prior on new the fresh data
really helped us and actually it barely
helped at least but you know I'm not
really sure this is due to the some kind
of
it's due to my station being harder is
it actually a kind of the limit abyss so
on the right hand side now I just
replace the plot of learning on all
feminist datasets actually the bound
does get quite a bit better compared to
the left hand side and this Oracle prior
distribution so we're the we're given
these optimal variances it's pretty
close to the test error now of course
this this tester by the way is for
randomized classifier and of course is
still quite poor but you know we're
still getting quite a bit closer so it
seems that there is if you can learn the
prior variance and some in some way
because we could improve the month quite
a bit so just to recap using the
fraction of the training data as Prime
sort of us to predict stochastic
gradient descent on all the data leads
to significant improvement over prior
centers and initialization now those go
samples did not really improve
predictions which is a little surprising
but as I said mainly we can still push
that idea forwards theory suggests this
type of data defendant prior may be
necessary for tight back basement so
again as I explained earlier the optimal
prior in some cases is not just this
data distribution dependent prior but
it's actually optimal to use some of the
training data to learn the prior of
course and the data distribution so you
need both and we're so far from studying
stochastic gradient descent itself so
skies of neural networks in our studies
were severely underfoot due to looseness
or the kale term during fact this
optimization we need to really
understand the Pareto optimal frontier
so it would be nice to understand for a
given risk or the randomized classifier
hard title visualization band we can get
so gives classifiers concentrated
nearest category in descent weights may
be fruitful or suggests differently in
their language or they use before tests
but for generalization ideas so kind of
to address Matisse's point we're hoping
we can learn something from this and
actually identify some structures that
are relevant for generalization a
careful empirical evaluation whether by
montt evaluation or causal analysis is
necessary to judge our understanding so
we should not only just plot how
correlated are aboundeth to the
generalization error when it's orders of
magnitude than the bandhas orders of
magnitude larger potentially but then we
should also perform some calls on
analysis to really understand whether
this quantity is of interest or of
course if we get that time bound then
perhaps you don't either causal analysis
despite impressive progress by community
we're still far from understanding
generalization deeper
[Applause]
we're free to choose the form of culet
we want right so for example using those
margin ideas it would really want
something concentrated to be motor
exploit those videos I'm not saying that
using margin is optimal in a way to do
random - backbase randomize class person
get to get actual bounce on the
deterministic classifier but it's just
one idea but in that case we would want
something tightly concentrated to use
the gifts distribution if we could
actually sample from gist distributions
you know we do a lot more have different
organization strategies this actually
may be a comment related to his question
so if you don't use a subset of the data
to create the prior as you did at the
end yeah if we just pick the prior
naively then we're we're forced to
actually I get a prior which puts mouse
on all the possible good points which we
know and even just by permutation and
silly things toward a large set yes and
so by so in fact one thing that makes
makes me wonder is that so you use the
subset of the data to construct your
your priors but I wonder if just using
the initialization alone as a prior with
was that the capable zero point zero
zero point and also so it depends
actually this not in this in the spot
it's terrible so one thing to notice
actually that the spot is not like this
can be done much better this is due to
optimization failure
I think you're talking about the means
being pretty good so in this case for
example but yeah just putting the prior
to neutralization Zico culture for
example or in his student read they had
those experiments where they show that
the distance this ultra distance to
initialization doesn't kind of decrease
as fast as you would like for the bands
as you increase in em right the number
of training data so other people have
done experiments like that kind of you
know seeing how important initialization
s and now our old work we used the
center tired prior set initialization
but in that word we also allow the
poster mean to deviate from a CD
solution so there we also optimize
variable center cue in this word we
really try to fix cue that HD found and
then constraint bands in this case
having the priorities neutralization is
actually not that good I think what's
really surprising is that now even using
this go sample so for K equals 0 this is
just using all fresh data to Center the
prior so we run into D on a fresh data
set and we Center our prior there that
it didn't really help much so it seems
that stochastic gradient descent like
you know strained on vision image data
sets and training cone neural networks
it's quite predictable when you use a
subset of the data but it's not really
predictable when you run stochastic
redesign of fresh data
so generally the generalization learning
so there are different types of
complexity measures and they all provide
upper bounds so for that place is a high
level based on the distance between the
front of this tribution bill started off
from yeah so I'm not aware of any
methodology we have right now for
understanding because it's really what's
driving generalization besides
experiments so can you comment on the
type of experiments you're aware of that
try to evaluate this hypothesis that
this is what is really controlling the
generalization about akhil divergence is
really what's controlling totalization
in very high level no you're not
specifically can for example maybe some
average over many runs and see if
there's a correlation between the final
generalization and how far the
distribution is or is yeah so I would
see so we do actually have some
experiments but again it's ongoing work
for trying to predict the distribution
of stochastic gradient descent in some
sense so as you said averaging over
multiple rings and so that work is
really ongoing can I cannot I guess tell
you kind of exact conclusions but I
think this is really trying to
understand whether KL divergence it's
interesting core maybe what kind of you
know we have a lot of flexibility in
fact these plans right what kind of
distributions we choose for Q and B
because we can she was really anything
yeah so we could you know if me are
running instead of HD weird running LD
and LD converges weakly to a from a
gives distributions then perhaps we can
evaluate something how relevant is kill
respect these balancing the kill
complexity terminus but for you should
be itself it's a little like there is no
station or distribution potentially
right it's a little harder to actually
save a certainty and whether this is a
quantity of interest than that just
because of like all the choices for
caring people good me
but it could be like just like to be the
situation for other complexity lenders
that this is not really what's Italy
honors there is something else
oh yeah Chris Chris I'm not saying that
this is the approach we have to take but
this is like we're really just trying to
understand how informative it is
so yeah relatedly part of the reason I
asked about the cross validation thing
is by baking in so we know that creating
dissent the norms of the parameters go
like log t we know that a lot of this
late very late dynamics are determined
by the intermediate than others so know
that if you create your prior halfway
through you've kind of already baked in
a lot of what's what's going on and so
I'm worried that the explanatory
properties of your bounder actually may
be the bound is lower but the
explanatory properties actually
diminished right by baking massage yes
it's interesting though of course I
don't need to think more about it I
think I'm still not really like I don't
think that we're definitely excluding
any explanatory power by this right so
it's really defensive whether you want
to explain the bulk of generalization
year or the last few percentage points
so I think it kind of relates to that
there's still enough structure of the
left trying to mean it can still like if
for example they didn't work I think
there is still quite a bit of tell if
they do work we can say something about
predictability of stochastic readings
and how predictable is it is for this
subset of the data so I think that's
already informative
we'll see you stopping at halfway to the
first epoch you run these things for
anything yeah you're saying - yeah and
particularly the training and test are
still very high when you when you choose
your prior so it's actually not there's
like a lot of work left to do not just
it just about back these pounds now Jen
do you think you're going to prove
generation bounce and test it on these
few data sets
theory overfitting
we have we managed to fit even what I
would use oh yeah I start from the same
random initialization for sure otherwise
I think the results would be quite a
friend actually maybe we should take her